welcome to this video playing struggler
don't know no no games against this kind
new opponent so the with Lopez five
beast 5d3 okay i'm going to try
something different against that let's
try to fianchetto know why it has a ton
of automatic moves that you can play
right now that's a good feature from a
practical point of view of the rule
oppressors ydf tons of moves night f 193
why not not g3 you are or h3 those kind
of moves
no no it's taking some time what is it
coming up with i think i would really
just play 83 or 93 and then see what I
do but he's not doing that maybe is just
disconnected nope am i disconnected nope
he is just thinking that's unpopular
nowadays but he did he just thought okay
night to g3 what am i doing now there
are many I than many possibilities I can
just I can even just play b5 d phi of
this kind of thing or Bishop d7 this is
the conservative way but I guess I'll go
for that why not gain some space yeah I
think Bishop c2 is probably right here
yes and now I was thinking just defy
maybe this is the wrongly timed opening
on the position I don't know okay let's
do that try to be active what I don't
like about this is that with the bishop
on g7 there's c5 really weakened ok yeah
I actually thought that both recaptures
might be might be feasible ok let's do
that
yeah why not queen is active on d5 he
can attack it with Bishop please be
three inputs I don't know it doesn't
look too scary I can go to the six yeah
my weekend Queen side is making noise
cause for some concern if the point
would be back on b7 I would be very
satisfied in this position but with a
pawn on d5 it can be a bit a bit tricky
on the other hand I'm the one with more
space and in fact even with more time
he's really taking lots of time there
okay he's threatening to take f6 take
age 6 mm yeah well this is very boring
but I have to take I guess yeah hmm yeah
boring boring boring but yeah okay well
it was his it was his choice and I
cannot really I cannot deviate from that
it's not threatening much all it's very
dangerous but we just trade stuff here
okay how to play now hmm is there any
way forward him is there something
active that I can do I don't know
probably looked in adium at least he
cannot trade everything on the default
because of the a true point okay it
seems that he tries to activate your
night to be three night to c5 this kind
of thing okay okay i wonder if i should
play a five or not f5 f3 f4 bishop ever
to Bishop f8
hmm debatable that that might be very
weakening um i would like to trade my
bishop them h5 king edge seven bishop
age six but this is very very slow just
play normal animals the ideas amongst
others Bishop e7 g5 I can even play
Bishop e7 giving away the porn i think
bishop is heaven bishop age 6 g 5 is
something that he has to worry about
probably ok mm-hmm so if we just check a
whole bunch no i think it that it must
be ok for me I don't think I rose him
mean I don't be three that talk all nice
and good but it doesn't really threaten
much and in some cases I can just take I
mean like rook d8 9895 I just take this
take a two and I have gotten the pawn
probably this is not better for black or
anything but it should be okay
and it's very Jewish I think unless I'm
overlooking some great idea that might
be there I'm not saying I'm not saying
there might not be there could be
something let's say that's what I try to
save without any exercise probably I can
go see 5c for now for the space and I
will do that i would like to play Bishop
c5 but he will take h7 so I have to
prepare that with age 5 or with 35 maybe
actually g5 thank you I know it looks
weird but it is the right color complex
compared to his bishop so that I fix his
pawns on light squares Oh interesting i
think she should have taken and played
this earlier to prevent the trades the
traits helped him I mean in terms of
equalizing the position not in terms of
an advantage yeah I am ok let's open
this up he cannot play bishops into I
will do it now now I have this move it's
difficult to protect the beep on I add
some pressure there on the queenside but
I think it could have defended by just
staying as to stay with the bishop on d1
ok so no it's still not a simple win you
can I should get get back here with the
might the age for porn is something that
I can attack he has created this new
weakness okay I'm taking I guess some
now in time one NC night at 493
threatening Knight to f5 okay so let's
cover that and if i go to g6 he has to
go back hmm King t5 hmm not sure if that
wins I maybe I could have taken at King
before actually check maybe maybe that
was possible this looks white there's
I'm yeah this is a song I think I made a
big blonde I he actually I think he can
take this and weird kinky for ok this is
winning I simply this was a real light
brain slip here I just have to do this
and this and win easily but 94 wow ok I
relax a little bit due to the time
situation yeah I think um around here
why does slightly better but you didn't
make anything out of it I really don't
don't know I mean if he has something
tangible
tangible and Joe with the weekend
queenside maybe it is really just just
very equal yeah but but I can definitely
say is that right here after I got to be
seven there's absolutely nothing totally
nothing and in fact i'm slightly more
comfortable here with the space maybe 95
am keeping stuff from the board but ok
this this is keeping a small edge but I
made a mistake i made one clear mistake
I should take now check and go here to
make sure that V 3 and a 4 is not
happening and in this position I can
yeah I can play forever yeah it is a
draw if he plays it right just the
defense okay but i can continue forever
with my space advantage it's a draw yes
but it's a draw that i am playing for
completely for two results and now check
it wasn't helping that he got de ponce
traded but yes so he made this mistake
and gave me the pawn yeah he was under
some pressure and he was 30 seconds down
so he gave me the pawn and a thing
afterwards I played okay up to this this
real brain brain slip when i when i
played them yeah and was it was a
Vietnam and this is ok with night f4 is
just and the moment I played it I saw
that yeah he maybe even could have done
that in 10 seconds sir check yeah and
I'm losing everything that that was
stupid but ok when you have a good run
as I do lately am sometimes people
really do what you want you want them to
do ok well thanks for watching